Frances president is hosting more than
50 world leaders and philanthropists in
Paris today for a summit on climate
change in his first American network TV
interview macron spoke to CBS Evening
News anchor Jeff Glor about his
differences with President Trump we have
direct discussions and and each time I I
take a decision or it takes a decision
we have a direct phone call and I do
respect him but we disagree dance to the
three issues and the very first one was
on climate and and what it told me is
that I took a commitment visibly my
voters and and I I told them it was not
good for the US and especially the US
workers
he says he's opened a renegotiation you
know you have more than 190 countries as
negotiators I'm not ready to renegotiate
with so many people I'm stirring around
the table when you sign a treaty you
have to respect it the u.s. is a great
government is a great country the u.s.
did sign the Paris agreement it's
extremely aggressive to decide on his
own just to live and no way to push the
orders to renegotiate because one
decided to leave the floor I'm sorry to
say that it doesn't fly so sorry but I
think it's a big responsibility in front
of the history and I'm pretty sure that
my friend president Trump will change
his mind in the coming month or years I
do hope you think he'll change his mind
yes I mean my I'm not ready to
renegotiate but I'm ready to welcome him
if he decides to come back